the left defends ante foe we talk about
Confederate statutes and why we're
really talking about Confederate statues
and we talk about the Republican
response to everything Trump related I'm
ben shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so if possible everything is worse
yesterday I left the show by saying can
we have a good day apparently no one
listened so they decided to have an
incredibly crappy day well done everyone
just a great jump around we're going to
talk today a lot about why the Left
seems to now be defending violence why
does it NT Phi has to be turned into
heroes why that was their ultimate goal
in the first place also we'll talk about
Confederate statues should they be
removed Confederate monuments why are we
even talking about Confederate monuments
what the goals are of the various
political sides and even discussing this
and we'll go through the various
arguments for and against keeping them
so it seems that the left had an
ulterior motive when it comes to the
events in Charlottesville I don't mean
that they organized the events in
Charlottesville with an intent toward
what happened to that that innocent
young woman or that it's their fault
they went their encounter protested an
evil white supremacist movement and
spare me all the talk about how there
were lots of wonderful people at the at
the evil white supremacist movement the
thing was pitched as an white
supremacist rally okay that's just the
way that it was okay but it is clear
that one of the goals of the left and it
has been for now a year and Charlotte's
will allowed them to do this with some
level of credibility is they are now
attempting pretty overtly to legitimize
the antifoam movement the antifa
movement is a deeply violent movement
that seeks to use violence against all
the people they oppose and the media
have basically covered up the level of
violence that Antipa is engaged in so
yesterday we got news that another rally
in Richmond Virginia where a bunch of
antique shop
there was a journalist who really got
clocked we have a couple of pictures
what happened to that journalist so here
is a picture of the journalist after the
journalist clocked by an MTF a member
and here is another picture of the
journalist head after the journalist was
clocked by the mt4 member for staples in
the head concussion from the antifa
member this was not covered in any real
way by the media more broadly they
basically suggested that none of this
sort of stuff happened
that when Trump said that the alt left
was charging into people that was that
was not true again it was true okay what
Trump said there was true he said some
things during that press conference that
really I thought were quite upsetting
morally but that was not one of them
when he went after the what he called
the all left by which he meant Antipa he
was exactly right to do so and Tifa is a
violent vile
and you're seeing this unfortunately
this notion spread around the country
then n Tifa violence against Nazis is
okay we have this conversation a while
back when Richard Spencer who is a
neo-nazi white supremacist was punched
in the head and a lot of people on the
Left celebrated yay Richard Spencer was
punched in the head and I said at the
time I think Richard Spencer is vile but
you can't punch Nazis in the head we
live in a civilized country hey you
shouldn't be punching people in the head
this is why we have police ideally it
means one thing to defend yourself it's
a full another thing to to go somewhere
with the intent of engaging in violence
but the left seems now ensconced in this
idea there were two washington post op
eds in the course of 48 hours basically
endorsing and Tifa so one of them was
from a professor named NDB Connelly of
Johns Hopkins University and he wrote an
entire piece called Charlottesville
showed that liberals that liberalism
can't defeat white supremacy only direct
action can in other words we can't have
votes we can't have conversations we
can't have debate no only white
supremacy the own white supremacy can
only be defeated by throwing what he
calls rocks and this is seriously what
do you rate your rights liberalism paper
preserves our country's long commitment
to contract under liberalism citizens
stand in contract with their government
the government's job in turn has been to
enforce contracts between individuals
and groups but Connolly continues white
supremacy represents our culture
scissors there have been people
historically cut out of our social
contract but there is a rock right it's
rock paper scissors there is a rock
resistance
okay resistance is the rock and he says
rocks can look like armed self-defense
or nonviolent direct action campaign
well those are not the same thing at all
in non-violent direct action campaigns
like boycott that's not the same thing
as punching somebody in the head or
throwing rocks he goes on to talk about
why violence is okay so in April 1968 I
made a flurry of other rocks riots shook
American cities following the
assassination of Martin Luther King jr.
it took that rolling unrest not the
promise that further economic growth
to spur President Lyndon Johnson in
Congress to action within a week they
had passed the Fair Housing Act remember
the past century liberalism vexed by an
ever sharp ever cutting white supremacy
has needed these rocks so riots are
necessary so burning down Detroit
burning down Los Angeles and Watts riot
that was necessary and then he concludes
segregationists have ass again assume
their pedestals in the Justice
Department the White House and many
other American temporal temples hey by
the way Jeff Sessions immediately called
this a hate crime and said who's going
to investigate this as a terrorist
incidents that's just nonsense and when
he says segregationist and the White
House Trump isn't the segregationist
okay I don't like what Trump said I've
been very clear that I didn't like what
Trump said on Tuesday or on Saturday I
think Trump sometimes fellow travels
with the alt-right because he thinks
they're his friends but he's not a
segregationist okay it connelly
concludes paper alone won't drive them
out start throwing rocks so overtly
calling for violence overtly calling for
violence in the streets in a country
that is highly law-abiding where levels
of violence are at their lowest levels
on average in 50 years basically I mean
this is this is really really vile stuff
it's by the way it's also historically
ignorance this is another point I think
worth making right in America have not
forwarded the cause riots in America I
have made the cause worse Detroit before
the Detroit riots of 1967 1968 before
those Detroit riots happen Detroit was
the fastest-growing black city in
America it was a an economic hub black
families earned ninety five percent on
average what white families earned in
the city of Detroit desegregation was
happening wholesale in Detroit housing
was being desegregated in Detroit and
then after the riots you got white
flight people left the tax base eroded
they raise taxes in order to take
advantage of whatever smaller tax base
was left more people left and that's how
you hollow out a major city like Detroit
rises on the same thing in LA LA is a
highly segregated today I've lived my
entire life here la is very very
segregated South Central Los Angeles or
South Los Angeles as they like to call
it now is is very black and East LA is
very Hispanic and Simi Valley is very
white okay it's a very segregated city
and one of the reasons is because of
riots like the LA riots or as Maxine
Waters that disgusting human being
called them the LA uprising when black
folks decided to many black folks had to
burn their own neighborhoods and target
Korean shopkeepers in in South Central
over the Rodney King verdict okay riots
throwing rocks is not a worthwhile thing
in the United States again self-defense
is one thing riots are not self-defense
riots are not self-defense I'm not
talking here about the lynch mob comes
to get a black guy and he shoots them
good for him more power to him that's
why the NRA is useful okay but I'm
talking here about what he's talking
about the idea then Antipa needs to go
out in the streets and if the Nazis are
marching and people needs to go out and
punch them in the head he's not the only
person saying this mark Bray is a
historian and lecturer at Dartmouth
University and he's defending anti fight
he was on MSNBC fully defending this
this vile violent communist anarchist
group how does how do far-right
movements grow I say they grow by
becoming normalized by not being
confronted by being able to present
themselves as family friendly and and
respectable so part of the reason why
the alt-right calls themselves alright
is to present that mainstream image and
the opposition that that equal people
showed in Charlottesville really marred
and tainted that so I think that by
showing up and confronting it it
prevents the ability of being able to be
presented as mainstream and and
connected that I think really you need
to be able to to prevent them from being
able to organize people who are involved
in politics know that from movement to
expand they need to be able to organize
and grow and if you stop that it
prevents it okay this is sure nonsense
what he is saying here that people who
engaged in violence with the Nazis and
white supremacists in Charlottesville
did the country of service absolute
absolute crap this is he wrote in his
piece that auntie fuh has been fighting
Klansmen and fascists for years and then
he specifically talks about how they
helped stop Hitler except for how they
didn't stop Hitler right he says in
retrospect the anti fascist have
concluded it would have much easier to
stop Mussolini back in 1919 when his
first fascist nucleus had 100 men or to
stamp out the far-right German Workers
Party which I had only 54 members when
Hitler attended his first meeting before
he transformed it into the National
Socialist German Workers Party so he
says that not just about it but he's
saying they shouldn't just do this
through education he says the first
anti-fascist fought Benito Mussolini's
black shirts in the Italian countryside
exchanged fire with Adolf Hitler's brown
shirts in the taverns and alleyways of
Munich and defended Madrid from
Francisco Franco's insurgent nationalist
army how'd that go
how'd that go all three of those times
the bad guys won so how'd that go
and I want to talk a little bit about
this myth that that armed violence by
communists in the bimah Republic would
have stopped the Nazis there was armed
violence by communists in the Weimar
Republic it was one of the driving
forces behind the Nazi success people
looked at the Communists they said okay
we have to decide between communist
violence and fascist violence we'll go
with the fascists it is from Richard
Evans's book the coming of the Third
Reich quote a graph that could counted
the life of the committed communist
activist during the Weimar Republic was
later provided by the memoirs of richard
krebs clashes with the police
strengthened his hatred of them and
their bosses the social democratic
rulers of the city the communists
refused to work with the social
democrats says
Krebs later described how committed
communists would attend street
demonstrations with pieces of lead
piping in their belts and stones in
their pockets ready to Pelt the police
with I want to tell you the rest of this
story and why it is that groups like NP
file only grow the alt-right only grow
the neo-nazis only grow the neo
Confederates only grow the white
supremacist but before I do that I first
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at brain bridge frame bridge comm
is the place to get a frame and to get a
really nice frame a customized frame for
very inexpensive prices here's the way
it works go to frame bridge comm you
upload your photo from your computer or
directly from your Instagram feed or if
you have a physical item you can send it
directly to them and they provide secure
secure prepaid packaging so you can mail
it in for free improve your photo online
and any frame style that you like you
can choose your favorite you can get
free help from a consultant the expert
team at frame bridge then delivers the
frame to your door in days not weeks or
months they deliver it ready to hang so
you stick it right on the wall and
instead of the hundreds that you would
pay in a framing store for a custom
frame their prices start at 39 bucks all
shipping is free as well I've used frame
bridge for my own posters they charge an
arm and a leg
and a lot of the custom framing places
around here if you want to own a frame
and poster for image is my frame bridge
is much less expensive and much nicer
actually my listeners right now get 15%
off their first order at frame bridge
comm when they use my code Shapiro frame
bridge calm and use my promo code
Shapiro right now they have a happiness
guarantee as well so if you're 100
percent satisfied with your order they
will make sure that it is right Shapiro
okay promo code Shapiro at frame bridge
comm again it's frame bridge comm slash
zero I've used them I'm very happy with
them and I think that you will be too
okay so
it wasn't just that the Communists and
the Nazis went at one another
paramilitary battles were common by the
way here are some statistics about the
paramilitary battles in the aftermath of
world war one the German army was
essentially disbanded by the Versailles
Treaty and there are a lot of
ex-military people roaming around the
Communists grab some of them and what
we're called the Freikorps the FRA
corpse grabbed FRA Corps grabs it grabs
another and they form things like the
steel helmets and the FRA Corps and
these were all these were all militia
groups basically local militia groups
that wandered the countryside fighting
each other and quote-unquote defending
the population from the various entities
from 1924 to 1929 it was claimed the 29
not the activists had been killed by
communist communist reported 92 workers
had been killed in clashes with fascists
from 24 to 30 26 members of the steel
helmets the steel helmets were sort of
this this veterans group were said to
have fallen in the fight against
communism in 1930 the figures rose
dramatically in the lead-up to the Nazis
taking power this was a key factor in
the rise of the Nazis in 1930 the
figures rose dramatically the Nazis
clintons have suffered 17 deaths rising
to 42 in 1931 84 in 1932 remember 1932
is the year the Nazis essentially paved
their way to power in 1932 the Nazis
reported nearly 10,000 of their
rank-and-file have been wounded in
clashes with their opponents
according mark Bray wouldn't that have
stopped them and me obviously had armed
resistance why didn't that stop them the
Communists reported 44 deaths in fights
at the Nazis in 1932 and 1931 75 in the
first six months of 1932 alone in the
number of dead in the year in the year
to March 1932 a March 1931 was no no
fewer than 300 dead in these various
battles I mean serious serious stuff
makes Charlottesville look like look
like a pikers game the number of people
who are dying in these meetings a
communist would break up Nazi meetings
in one meeting Krebs went and he broke
up a Nazi speech by Hermann Goering
right Garen would become the second in
command to Hitler he said that he quote
made sure that each man was armed the
blackjack for brass knuckles
a terrifying melee followed Blackjacks
brass knuckles clubs heavy buckle belts
glasses bottles were the weapons used
Goering he stood currently on the stage
his fist on his hips Evans reports
scenes like this were being played out
all over Germany in the early 1930s the
Nazis made their money
off these sorts of things if you want to
make the alt-right more popular all you
have to do is go out in the streets and
fight them then they get to look tough
they get to look like they win they get
to look like they're victims at the same
time like they're fighting a defensive
battle when really what they're doing is
promulgating an evil ideology again this
is Richard Evans okay gurbles made his
reputation above all as regional leader
of Berlin where his fiery speeches his
incessant activity his outrageous
provocations of the Nazis opponent and
his calculated staging of street fights
and meeting hall brawls to gain the
attention of the press won the party a
mass of new adherents young disenchanted
men who have nothing better to do with
their lives are looking for movement to
belong to and that will engage in
violence and makes them feel tough it
makes them feel special this is why you
see you know Christopher Cantwell in
that in that vice video talking about
how many guns he carries and how he
works out all the time and makes himself
more ready for violence this is a thing
okay and when NFL plays right into their
hands not only are they doing something
evil when they shut down normal
conservatives they're doing something
evil when they fight these Nazis in the
streets with their fists okay that's why
we have police in this country we have
very able police in this country and the
idea that we need an Tifa in the streets
is some sort of grand and glorious
mission is really disgusting it's a way
of legitimizing a group that by the way
is communist the anarchist and fights
law-abiding people too not just white
supremacists
not just white supremacist but this is
just in line with it's something that I
think is really terrible because I think
everyone is taking advantage of racial
conflagrations like this they're they're
taking advantage of hot points like this
to promulgate an image of their
opponents so the whole point this is why
we're talking about conservatives
Confederate statues rather so the reason
that we're talking about Confederate
statutes is become a major issue now
because President Trump decided to make
that an issue at his press conference a
couple of days ago because the rally for
the white supremacists took place around
the robert e lee statue and because the
left is now calling for stone mountain
to be taken down and they're talking
about how they need to get rid of
various monuments all over the united
states that include confederate figures
or pre confederate figures so we need to
ask ourselves why are we even having
this conversation and I think it's worth
recalling that in the aftermath of that
evil piece of crap Dylann storm roof
shooting 19 black people murdering 19
black people at a black church a
historically black church
Dylann storm roof
there's a picture of him with a
confederate flag and we had a whole
national conversation about the
confederate flag why is it that whenever
somebody does something evil we
immediately jump to try to find some
divisive symbol that we can all rally
around or against why is that we do that
and I would suggest that it has very
little to do with the symbol and a lot
more to do with political gamesmanship
it has a lot more to do with people
trying to make political hay ok so let's
start at the beginning here the
controversy over Confederate statutes
has been a hot-button issue for decades
ok there are good arguments on both
sides in a second I'm going to go
through the arguments on both sides and
what they mean and and whether they are
worthwhile but the question is why in
the aftermath of what we just saw in
Charlottesville are we now talking about
getting rid of all the Confederate
statutes I mean like a year ago we got
rid of all the Confederate flags
supposedly and that obviously didn't
tamp things down so why is that we keep
going back to iconoclasm I kind of class
and literally means taking down icons
why is it or attempting to do that now
why is that an important thing okay
we're actually participating I think in
a politically advantageous proxy
argument the people who want to get rid
of the statues want to label everyone
who wants to keep the statues a member
of the all-white right supremacists okay
that's actually what they want to do so
people who say if you want to keep the
statute that's because you're white
supremacists and then people who don't
want to get rid of the statues they say
in contrast that everyone who wants to
get rid of the statues just wants to
wipe away American history now there are
people who back the Confederate statues
who actually are white supremacists as
we saw in Charlottesville and there are
a lot of people on the Left who want to
use the Confederate statues as a club
issue and want to get rid of all of
American history they wanna get rid of
Jefferson in Washington and what Trump
was saying is true there is a cadre of
people who absolutely that is on their
agenda but those aren't the real honest
arguments about this particular
Confederate statue or that particular
Confederate statue all of this all of us
can all this chaos all of this fighting
all of it is being done in order to
build particular movement so let's start
with the outright why do they have their
rally around the robert e lee statue in
Charlottesville Virginia in the first
place well they chose to protest the
removal for two reasons one their actual
white supremacists who find the
arguments of the Confederacy attractive
about the racial supremacy of whites to
blacks okay but more importantly
the real reason they did this is because
they know that there are many non white
supremacists right there are a lot of
people who are not white supremacist who
also oppose getting rid of the robert e
lee statue on other grounds historic
grounds cultural grounds the grounds
that maybe this is a good opportunity to
teach their children about the evils of
slavery and the problems of confederacy
and what the outright use these statues
is rallying cry because they're trying
to draw it closer to the normies right
they're trying to say that normal people
who don't wanna get rid of the statues
by the way the polls show a vast
majority of americans are not interested
in getting rid of these statues
including according to some polls the
majority of blacks the idea that
everyone wants to get rid of the statute
is nonsense the alt-right knows this and
so they pick a cause they think has a
majority of support like let's not get
rid of this robert e lee statue and then
they rally around that opening to
broaden their cause so the left reacts
in exactly the flip-side way so just as
with Dylann storm roof the left decides
that it's very important now to label
everyone who is their opponents a nazi
right so everyone who opposes getting
rid of these statues is now a member of
the alt-right according to the left
according to an antique fund the hard
left there are no good people who
believe this now it's not the same thing
as what Trump said Trump said there were
good people who went to that rally on
Friday night I seriously doubt that but
what the right is saying is that there
are some good people who believe that
you shouldn't get rid of the statute
undoubtedly true the left is saying
there are no good people then there are
no good people who believe that you
shouldn't get rid of the statue and it
is the same thing with the Confederate
flag the idea was anybody who flies a
Confederate flag must be a redneck
racist who wants to murder black people
and it wasn't true then it's not true
now and it's not fair about statues how
about President Trump well President
Trump also is acting out of political
convenience so the left has now
broadened the rubric of bad guys to
include anybody who opposes getting rid
of the leaf statue so Trump responds by
defending anyone anyone who doesn't want
statues of lead torn down as decent this
is why he's tried to broaden out the
argument right he's tried to say that
not only are there a lot of decent
people who don't want to get rid of the
leaf statues but you know those people
hang out with white supremacist on
Friday night right that's the problem so
everybody is now so it's the worst of
all world you exactly all right trying
to unite with the normies who don't want
to get rid of the of the Confederate
sketch
and then you've got the left trying to
unite the Normans with the alt-right by
saying all of them don't want to get rid
of the Confederates catch and then you
have Trump saying saying on behalf of
the normies well you know we're sort of
on the same side as the alt-right we
don't want to get rid of the
Confederates caches and so we end up
with is this very very polarized
politics and you're seeing it on the
left routinely
and I think the left started this by by
trying to use the Confederate statues as
flashpoint and suggesting that everybody
who wants to keep them is racist but I
think that the right and the alt-right
jumped on it and now the right is
falling into the trap and I don't say
that the right should get rid of the
statues but I think that we should at
least understand which arguments are
really going on okay the arguments that
are really going on or not the honest
arguments I'm gonna talk about the
honest arguments over Confederate
statues in just a minute because there
are honest arguments on both sides I
really do see them okay I really do see
the honest arguments on both sides and
I'll tell you about them but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Beachbody on demand so you
wouldn't know it to look at me
but dude I'm chiseled okay I am just a
monster and a lot of that is due to
Beachbody on demand they have all the
familiar brands the ones that you like
p90x insanity 21 day fix Beachbody on
demand gives you access unlimited access
to a wide variety of highly effective
world-class workouts if you're on the
road as I very often M it's perfect
during the hotel you don't have to have
your gear with you I like working out at
the gym but if there's no gym available
Beachbody on demand is the best plus
they now have dieting programs nutrition
programs you know I've been using p90x
and it is a great program for sure you
feel better you sleep better actually
and you're just generally healthier
naval 100 recipe videos to where you
learn how to prep your meals you can
cook kit or vegan friendly meals you can
practice your bartending skills with
healthy cocktails this is a brand new
service from Beachbody on demand already
has over a million members all you have
to do in to claim your free trial
membership is you text Shapiro to 30 30
30 so you text the number 30 30 30 and
you text the word Shapiro to them and
you get full access to the entire
platform for free for free for their
trial membership so you get that trial
membership and again this is step by
step program guides workout calendars
comprehensive nutrition plans everything
you need for working out everything
you need for being healthy and living a
healthier life you can do over a
Beachbody on demand all you have to do
is text the word Shapiro to 30 30 30 of
course by texting Shapiro 2 30 30 30
you're also letting them know that we
sent you as well okay so now I want to
go through a couple of the actual honest
arguments with regard to the Confederate
statues because the only reason we're
having this debate in the first place is
so everyone can demagogue it so they all
right can demagogue it pretend that
everybody who opposes them wants to wipe
away American history and they are
really just siding with the normal
American you've got president Trump
demagogue met by saying that there are
lots of good people who opposed getting
rid of the Confederate statues therefore
a lot of the people on Friday night who
are with these white supremacists are
fine
and then you have less demagoguing it by
saying anyone who doesn't want to get
rid of the Confederate statues is
obviously an evil neo Confederate
everyone's demagogue mean so let's talk
about the actual arguments here so this
morning president Trump tweets out three
tweets on this and the first tweet he
tweets excuse me
in sweet sad to see the history and
culture of our great country they ripped
apart with the removal of our beautiful
statues and monuments you can't change
history but you can learn from it robert
e lee's Stonewall Jackson who's next
Washington and Jefferson so foolish also
the beauty that is being taken out of
our cities towns and parks will be
greatly missed and never able to be
comparable irreplaceably making three
arguments here
the first argument is that statues of
Confederate history should be left up to
preserve our history and culture he's
not the only one who's made this
argument before Condoleezza Rice has
made it from a slightly less from a
slightly less positive point of view
here's kind of Lisa rice making pretty
much exactly that case I am a firm
believer in keep your history before you
and so I don't actually want to rename
things that were named for slave owners
I want us to have to look at those names
and recognize what they did and be able
to tell our kids what they did and for
them to have a sense of their own
history when you start wiping out your
history sanitizing your country to make
you feel better
it's a bad thing okay so she's making
the same case the Trump is making and I
agree with this basic case I think this
case is basically right that you leave
the ugly parts of your history up so
that people know about it and also it is
worthwhile noting that there are a lot
of people who are descendants of
Confederate soldiers who see the
monuments not as homage to slavery as
homage to slavery but as homage as to
people
who thought they were defending their
states from federal encroachment even if
they were defending an evil cause in the
process right so I think there's a
little bit more complexity than just
everyone who likes the Confederate
statues is a racist bigoted sexist
homophobe okay and I think that Connie
makes a good case and I think the case
there is is relatively strong what's
undercutting that case is the white
supremacists actively doing what the
left thinks most of America thinks about
the Confederates so I make that clear
let's believe that most Americans think
that these statutes should staff because
they're racist the actual reason that
white supremacists want the statutes
stay up is because they're racist so
it's it's hard it's a serious problem
that the white supremacists are taking
and using these symbols as rallying
points it's really quite demoralizing I
guess the second argument that Trump
makes is the slippery slope argument
this is actually trump strongest
argument is one that he made on on
Tuesday he said that the left wants to
wipe away all vestiges of American
history right they want to get rid of
Washington they want to get rid of
Jefferson this is certainly true okay
there are members of the left who want
to do this there's already talk Alton is
talking about how he wants to get rid of
statues people are talking about
changing the name of Washington DC even
though that as I mentioned yesterday
University of Missouri there was a
strong push to get rid of statues of
Thomas Jefferson in fact I showed you
video from that I showed you video from
that vice documentary about what
happened in Charlottesville and one of
the things that happened is there was a
black woman who was talking and she said
Thomas Jefferson's house it's up there
on that hill the slave masters house
it's up there on that hill and we should
get you know that's just another
monument that's Charlottesville okay so
the idea that this stops with robert e
lee is not true it will go back to
Thomas Jefferson no question now it
doesn't have to it doesn't have to and
if we were logical I think there's a
fairly strong case for getting rid of
monuments to Lee but keeping monuments
to Thomas Jefferson the case for getting
rid of the monument to lead but keeping
the cave but keeping the one for Thomas
Jefferson is that number one robert e
lee himself opposed building monuments
to Confederate soldiers because he
thought that it would prevent unity
which apparently he was right but second
robert e lee was fighting for a rebel
cause to break away from the Union
George Washington was fighting to uphold
the Union the question when you build
the monument is what are you celebrating
when you build a monument to MLK you are
not celebrating MLK's sexual
peccadilloes right when when you build a
monument to MLK you're celebrating his
message
on race relations when you build a
monument to George Washington you're not
celebrating a slaveholding you're
celebrating his actions in the
Revolutionary War in his establishment
of the Constitution and his presidency
right these are the things you're
celebrating monuments celebrate causes
not just the people who are on the
monuments and so that's how you
distinguish them right so Lee was for
the rebellion what are you celebrating
when you celebrate Lee right maybe maybe
you're making the case that you're
celebrating a man who honorably thought
that he was fighting for states rights
even though he opposed slavery and or
apparently supposed labor and was and
after he lost the war was was
instrumental in trying to rally the
country around the common point again
maybe that's what the monument is for
but that's a conversation worth having
there's no question when you have a
Jefferson Memorial for example that that
is not a monument to Jefferson's affair
with Sally Hemings that is a monument to
to Jefferson being the father of the
Declaration of Independence clearly
that's what the monument is for so you
don't have to engage in the slippery
slope the difference between slippery
slope arguments people get this wrong
all the time this is the difference
between slippery slope arguments and
application of principle arguments a
slippery slope argument says if you
allow them to do a then they'll do B if
you allow them to do B then they'll do
see an application of principle argument
like for example the argument that gay
marriage will lead to polygamy that's
not actually a slippery slope argument
the argument there is that same-sex
marriage redefines marriage as people
who love each other
polygamy can also be people who love
each other so you're applying the same
principle and you're just filling out
what that principle means right so
that's not the same thing as a slippery
slope argument this is an actual
slippery slope argument if you allow
them to take leave then they will also
take Jefferson in Washington
unfortunately it's a true argument as
the left is showing everyday and Trump
is not wrong about all of this now get
to the third argument that Trump makes
in just a second but for that you're
going to have to go over to Daley wire
calm right now and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you get this show live right we're
a video show you get this show live at
the end reclaim and show live that's
happening at 10:30 you get the Michael
Noel's show live that happens at 1:30 in
the afternoon and they're all wonderful
they're all worth watching you can part
the mailbag in each and go give them a
listen Michael I thought did a really
interesting interview yesterday with a
fellow who attended the Charlottesville
March and so you can go listen to that
it's it's real
worth listening to yet all those things
when you become a subscriber you get to
be part of the mailbag on all of those
shows plus you know their ads in our
show when we repost the shows later you
can cut those ads out though the ads
don't exist in the reposting that we do
later just for members so you just get
the show completely straight without ads
if you become a subscriber for $99 ear
you get all of those things plus you get
this the most magnificent of all vessels
you left this tears hot or cold mug much
sought after much desired I got an email
from a guy yesterday who tries to make
his own by posing by pasting a piece of
paper onto a hot mug no no no that is
not right this is the only the
inimitable you cannot duplicate it it
cannot be imitated the leftist here's
hot or cold mug you get that for $99 a
year plus all those other wonderful
things and you support us allow us to
bring you the show which is of course
the most important thing so go over
there and check it out if you want to
listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud make sure that you leave us a
review and subscribe we always do
appreciate it we continue to be very
very strong on the iTunes charts we are
by far the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
Oh
okay so the third argument that Trump
makes with regard to these Confederate
statues is that the statues are
aesthetically pleasing this is a very
dumb argument so this is the worst of
his arguments that we'll never be able
to beautify our parts again if we don't
have a statue of Nathaniel Bedford
Forrest I'm pretty sure it'll be okay
I'm pretty sure we'll begin that that's
not a particularly good argument I think
there's an argument for some of them
like I think that stone mountain is an
amazing Monument I mean just
aesthetically it's an amazing thing I
mean they carved these giant monuments
into a mountain that's pretty incredible
but I don't think that you know some of
the some of these statues that exist on
street corners that nobody's looked at
in 40 years I don't think that those are
that's a very weak case as opposed to
the case that you see from a lot of a
lot of people on the Left which i think
is a fair case or they say hey I'm a
black taxpayer and I don't feel like
paying for somebody polished the shoes
of Nathaniel Bedford Forrest I think
that's totally fair I think it's a
totally fair argument so those are
arguments we can have though right I
mean I'm just presenting you all the
argument those are arguments we can have
we're not going to have any of those
arguments we're going to stand in our
various corners and scream at each other
because that's what politics has become
outstandingly in the corners screaming
at each other the fringes getting West
fringy the fringe is getting more
violence and things getting worse I
think that unfortunately Charlottesville
may be the beginning rather than the end
which is which is terrifying in its own
right between an Tifa and and the
alt-right just wow I think things are
moving in the wrong direction
okay I mean while President Trump is
trying to recover from the foolishness
of holding a press conference that was
completely counterproductive he his
business counsel basically resigned on
him and the CEO of IBM presented a
letter saying we disbanded Business
Council
he wrote team by now you've heard the
news we have disbanded the president's
strategy in policy form in the past week
we have seen and heard of public events
and statements that run counter to our
values as a country and a company IBM
has long said and more importantly
demonstrated its commitment to a
workplace in a society that it's open
inclusive and provides opportunities to
all then they denounce Charlottesville's
and then they say we have worked with
every US president since Woodrow Wilson
we are determining lean on partisan and
we have always believed dialogue is
critical to progress that's why I joined
the president's forum earlier this year
this group can no longer serve the
purpose for what
was formed we agreed to disband the
group okay so they agreed to disband the
group so Trump tweets out that you can't
you can't quit you're fired
it's an I'm ending the counselor says
rather than putting pressure on the
businesspeople of the manufacturing
council and strategy and Policy Forum
I'm ending both thank you all mmm okay
when they when they issue a letter like
who do you believe you think Trump
disbanded the forum or do you think the
the people who are the CEOs were going
to leave and then Trump disbanded the
forum or they decided to disband it
themselves none of this is good
apparently Trump is very proud of
himself for this press conference
Steve Annan is very proud of him for
this press conference because he feels
like finally we get down to the the root
of the battle finally we get down to the
identity politics battle in fact Steve
said that directly to the New York Times
you said the lots been engaging in
identity politics for a while let them
continue to do that and we'll just play
off of that it's not a good thing the
President of the United States should
not be celebrating the rise of identity
politics on the left even though it's
destroying the left I don't think you
should be celebrating that you should be
fighting it with every tooth and nail in
his body every bone in his body should
be fighting that with instead I think
that he's engaging with it I am
apparently Trump was telling people that
he has no regrets I think that he should
actually get the tattoo that says no
regrets it's like should at this point
have some regrets about about what state
you see the country and and obviously
this is not all trump's fault it was
like this before
Obama had exacerbated racial tensions to
a tremendous degree look at the Gallup
polls but this is definitely not helping
Bandhan by the way seems to be in
trouble
Bandon did that he did an interview with
The American Prospect he called up a guy
at the American Prospect which is a very
far left organization and began ranting
to him about globalists like Gary Cohn
and he started yelling about Trump's
North Korea policy saying there's no
chance we're going to joining military
in North Korea obviously and and then
the guy printed it and so bandhans been
trying to backtrack ever since I think
the greatest part of this particular
story is that clearly whatever disease
the mood chad is infectious it is a
contagious disease the mood calls up a
reporter forgets to say it's off the
record and then apparently ban and says
he did the exact same thing not smart
but Bandhan maybe on the skids the
easiest thing for Trump to do right now
by the way is fire abandoned and then
say listen I have to disassociate from
all these people they're really bad
is from going to do that I'm skeptical
I'm skeptical maybe he fires Bannon but
I don't think that he trump is a guy who
always doubles down always doubles down
and that means that if you know he's
bluffing you should definitely play
poker with him because he will just
continue to double down he'll go all-in
on nothing he'll go all-in not even a
pair of two's he'll go all-in on you
know two seven offsuit it's really it's
an unfortunate tendency it's for
Republicans in a weird position so the
left has been saying a lot of people in
the media been saying when do the
Republicans disassociate when do they
turn on Trump Jeffrey Toobin for example
on CNN he says Republicans are just
reminded of yuqing him when will they
really turn on him know if we're talking
about whether you can function as
president of the United States and he
can certainly function because the
Republican Party is not going to abandon
him Mitch McConnell said he was upset
you know I'm upset when I can't find a
good parking place I mean it is the
mildest kind of rebuke do you think
Mitch McConnell is not going to fight
for tax reform now do you think that the
Republican Party is going to stop trying
to disenfranchise African Americans like
it's doing all over the country because
Donald Trump said something bad this is
what the Republican Party's stand me you
want to know why the Republicans aren't
abandoning Trump because what the left
means by abandoning Trump is not a thing
I keep hearing this that I'm hearing
this actually from some people with whom
I largely agree on politics saying you
know that if you call balls and strikes
on Trump then you're doing it wrong
because you just have to disassociate
totally from Trump it's not a matter of
just how do you disassociate from a
human being like what does that mean
just like never talk to me I don't talk
to Trump now what does it mean to
disassociate from him I can't say I
can't support anything he does ever I
have to I have to yell at every single
thing he does like this is clearly what
the media would like Chuck Todd says
that Republicans have to call out Trump
they're not doing it enough but I'll
tell you how on earth is the party going
to confront this crisis if it's
unwilling to stand up against the person
who arguably instigated it we invited
every single Republican senator on this
program tonight all 52 we asked roughly
a dozen House Republicans including a
bunch of committee chairs and we have
roughly a half dozen former Republican
elected official
none of them agreed to discuss this
issue with us today so who's going to
step up the president has lost his moral
authority for now and in the process
he's tried to destroy or discredit
everyone else's have all of our elites
lost their moral authority or are they
afraid to find out that the answer might
be yes okay so and this is it this is
the pitch of the media's that every
Republican ought to be coming out and
yelling about this okay so number one
there are some of us who have been
yelling about this right I mean like
I've obviously been very exercised over
president Trump's failures to
disassociate from the from the all right
however what the left really wants and
this is why I think you're seeing fewer
Republicans who are resonating to what
the left wants the left is not
intellectually honest about what they
want
okay the like I don't know what they're
talking about they say high-level
Republicans won't say anything right
here's years Ronda McDaniels he's the
head of the RNC and she's directly
addressing white supremacists and I
think this is right well the president
condemned the white supremacist and the
KKK and the neo-nazis unequivocally it
took 48 hours we're going to do that but
he did it and he should have and he did
and our party has across the board said
this is unacceptable we have no place in
our party at all for KKK anti-semitism
race racism bigotry it has no place in
the Republican Party there is no home
here we don't want your vote we don't
support you will speak out against you
the president has said so the vice
president leaders across our party this
is the beginning of what needs to be a
longer conversation we are seeing this
rhetoric ramped up we are seeing more
violence and we need to take a stand
against you okay so obviously everybody
is willing to condemn alikes problems
why won't they condemn Trump why won't
they when will they speak Trump's name
because they understand and this is
really one of the problems with
political partisanship I'm willing to
say the President Trump did something
wrong except I think he did something
wrong here but what you are seeing is
that what the left really wants is they
think that you have not condemned from
strongly enough unless you embrace their
agenda that's really what they want Jeff
Sessions who's Crump's Attorney General
he came out immediately and said this
could be a civil rights violation or a
hate crime right it's not enough here's
what session said I don't think we
should just feel like we've got to do it
in a matter of hours or days this
investigation is ongoing around the
country it could be 2:45 a civil rights
Val
nation title 18 to 45 or to 49 which is
a hate crime and there might be other
charges that could be brought ok so he's
obviously taking the thing very
seriously but the left actually want and
this is why you're seeing there's a poll
today that said 67% of Republicans
approve of Trump's response that's
because once again when you poll
Republicans about what they think of
Trump you're really pulling them about
what they think of the media when you
pull Republicans about what what they
think of Trump they're actually
responding to what they think of the
media because they know the media are
asking them a question and they think
the ulterior motive of the media is to
destroy Trump and by proxy to destroy
the Republican policy and governing
agenda so when people say sure I support
how Trump handled charlotte's though it
doesn't necessarily mean they actually
like how Trump handled charlottesville
many of them probably in the in the
privacy of their own homes and when they
discuss what their Republican friends
are not particularly happy with what
Trump did with charlottesville but
they're not going to tell that to a
pollster from the Washington Post
instead what they're going to say is
fine it's you against Trump I'm with
Trump because that that's the way that
the left has drawn the battle lines and
that's the way the right has responded
by drawing the battle lines so instead
of the here's the way a normal
conversation should go right the left
says Trump did something wrong here and
the right says yes Trump did something
wrong here and left says good we all
agree but that's not how the
conversation goes what happens the left
says Trump did something wrong here and
the right says yes Trump did something
wrong here or they prepare to say that
and then lessons you know what even if
you say Trump did something wrong here
you still agree with him because you
want to pass this tax agenda and so what
this leads to is sort of a game of
chicken is written prisoner's dilemma as
I've explained a game there's more of a
prisoner's dilemma where the best option
for both sides the dominant strategy for
both sides is to fall into the trap of
defending their man so if you're a
Republican and you know that the
Democrats next step is to say even if
you condemn it you're still a racist and
you say fine I'm just not going to
condemn it I know what your real agenda
here is your real agenda it's your
slander mate so screw you I'm not
engaging that's what these polls are
actually showing I don't think the polls
are showing the Republicans are racists
or bigots I think what the polls are
actually showing is the Republicans hate
the media and so they are unwilling to
answer the questions of the media
honestly I really think that's what it
comes down
okay so time for a quick thing I like
anything I hate there are enough Big
Ideas today so we won't do Big Idea
Thursday so things I like I just I
couldn't stop laughing at this last
night so last night I went to a ball
game and my white socks who are 50 games
under 500 we're playing the Dodgers who
are 50 games over 500 and the White Sox
were winning and they were winning 4-2 -
they have a new young guy named Nicky
Delmonico's just a terrific player I hit
two home runs in the game and a single
and he was playing a terrific terrific Y
field and just great player everything
was going swimmingly
and then my dad and I know that the
wheels are going to come off so we leave
at the bottom of the eighth-inning and
naturally the wheels do come off and the
Dodgers win 5-4 so that was I had lots
of fun at the game it was it was nice
there were a couple of people who
tweeted so that I was at the game
tweeted where I was so I did some
pictures that was fun so hello all of
you who are listening who were at the
game last night but the best baseball
moment was not just me and my dad at the
game last night which was a blast the
best baseball moment of yesterday was
the worst first pitch ever this is an
amazing first pitch and this I guess
happened at the Red Sox game pretty
incredible I mean you got to give credit
to this guy this is this is hard to do
so if you can't see it dude is throwing
out the first pitch and nickels we got
right in the nads just a bit outside
suggestive inside man that is not a good
first pitch I'm not sure who threw that
first pitch but kudos to him for
bringing America together again he's
making America great again I think with
that first pitch he even tweeted I think
the guys were tweeted who knew that
America could begin the healing process
with a with a fastball with testicles
and so well done Red Sox first pitch
guys okay now for the thing I hate
so the thing I hate today is the thing
that I've hated for many in many in many
a months and that of course is John
Mackay Tech a Raisin in the Sun a man
who looks like the wanted receipt you
left in your pocket and then sent it
through the wash John Kasich the
Governor of Ohio the most
self-aggrandizing human being ever the
person who single-handedly allowed
Donald Trump to become the nominee of
the party by refusing to get out and let
us have an honest vote between Ted Cruz
and Donald Trump in a latter part of the
of the race he stayed in for no reason
other than he's an egoistic and
now he says he wants to primary Trump
this is and so he's out there bashing
Trump because he wants to primary Trump
pathetic isn't it just pathetic
listening to this and hearing these
marchers think if you were a 8 9 or 10
year old getting ready to go to school
like they are in Ohio and you happen to
come from a Jewish family or you're
african-american and you hear this kind
of hatred and we know about bullying
that goes on in the schools and what are
we doing to our children and to not
condemn these people who went there to
carry out violence and to somehow draw
some kind of equivalency to somebody
else reduces the ability to totally
condemn these hate group okay so um
here's my problem
okay my problem is not with some of the
things that he's saying here but my
problem is that John Kasich obviously
has political and ambition and political
agenda and that's what infuses all of
this I mean it doesn't sound like an
honest pay from Kasich Kasich has been
criticizing for Trump but criticizing
Trump over everything large and small
and as I've said since the beginning of
this administration you got to wait to
turn the needle up to eleven four times
when it deserves to be turned up to 11
John Kasich seems like a cynical
manipulator the idea that he's going to
run in the primaries against Trump is
just idiotic okay if he runs in the
primaries against Trump he'll get 20% of
the vote maximum and it's and it's
largely because most of the people who
oppose Trump opposed him from the right
not from the left and Kasich is coming
at him from his left so that's not going
to be helpful at all John Kasich you
egotist it is largely your fault the
Donald Trump won the nomination in the
Republican Party in the first place and
then here you are doing this routine
just go away just go away okay so we'll
be back here tomorrow
I
for you again everyone try to have a
nice day and then tomorrow we can talk
about nice things and we'll do the
mailbag tomorrow so that'll be fun at
least I'm venture taro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]